[Music]
thank you
hello
hi
[Music]
it's a nice Sunday morning
um
9am which is earlier than I'm usually
yeah hi everyone
hi I'm just gonna I completely forgot to
open up the
um the post where people put their
earlier questions so I'm going to open
that up now
I can remember where it is
foreign
but yeah
um so this was meant to be like a 350
000 subscriber actually I think it might
have been a 3 000 subscriber live chat
but then I'm really bad at
um organizing things quickly and then I
forgot and yeah hi everyone
yeah
um
so originally this was going to be like
a fundraising live chat there's like a
bunch of different
um
Charities that I support a lot of the
time one of them is Ashley the Asylum
Seekers Resource Center
um in Australia which I've been donating
to for I don't know how long maybe 10
years
um and there's like this YouTube
function where if people donate then
their comments get bumped up and so I
was thinking that would be a nice way to
sort out which comments to answer first
um but then it turns out Australians
can't use that function so
um yeah like we can do live chats but we
can't do fundraiser live chats so
YouTube will take I believe it's a 30
cut of any
um money put in if it's not a fundraiser
live chat and I thought that was just a
lot so I think
um yeah if anyone is interested in
donating to them they're really great um
they do some really great work with
Asylum Seekers
um yeah
yeah
the name is as
um RC I'll put it in the
um in the comments at some point when I
work out how that works
alrighty so um I might start with some
skin care questions
um
so let me go through what's being in
here already
um so evidence for copper peptide um I'm
not sure how much there is
I haven't looked into peptides that much
even though peptides was my PhD topic
um and it's mostly because a lot of it
is really not transparent a lot of it is
like company
um just like research that companies
have done there's not much peer-reviewed
research there's not much independent
research and so I I don't know I find it
a bit difficult to evaluate that stuff
because obviously there's a lot of
potential bias and a lot of that company
research they won't show you their
methodology they'll show you very
limited data
um
they won't describe their methodology
properly a lot of it they won't even
give you any information unless you're
about to buy the copeptide
um if you pretend you're going to buy
the copper peptide or whatever
ingredient to get the information after
a while they realize that you're not
buying anything and then they ban you
from um getting more info and so it's
just a bit of a pain to get the
information
um but my hat my friend Hannah English
she's looked into them more than I have
and she
um she thinks they're pretty good for
sensitive skin I'm not sure about
collagen though but I feel like she's
probably got some info on it so sorry
that is not a very useful answer but she
might have some stuff
um
okay
mixing trash and no one is bad because
of consistency
um I don't think that's actually oh
right consistency it's
um I don't know if I said that I think
it's fine if you mix it in your hand
um I don't think it's okay if you mix it
in bulk so the problem with bulk is
um that's if you squeeze a whole tube of
trash into a jar of body cream like a
big pump of body cream which some people
have been doing
um so the reason that's bad is firstly
you mess up the preservative system of
both
um or you potentially could I guess it's
not like a straight up you will but
there's that risk and so it that means
that you're going to have lots of
microbes growing in your product before
um it normally would which means yeah
you're just wasting a whole bunch of
tretinoin and body cream
um the other issue is tretinoin is
really unstable lots of things
destabilize it including some
surfactants that are quite common in
production and by surfactants I mean
emulsifying surfactants
um so it's what's holding the cream
together
and if that happens obviously your
treasure known decomposers and again you
end up with no tretinoin before
you should like the treasurement breaks
down stops working very quickly
um I've seen some people say mixing
treasure known as bad because you can't
mix it properly with the other stuff
um I don't think that's correct so
um what that means is if you mix trash
and arm with something else in your hand
before you apply it
um I've seen some people warning against
that and I think there's a
misunderstanding that
so mixing things together before
applying is bad because
um it's bad for sunscreen
the reason that's bad is because
how things mix together really changes
how even a film it forms on your skin
um so if you've got holes in it then the
UV gets through and damages your skin
um now that happens if you even have
like a once off
um it's just a lot safer not to mix the
sunscreen layering it should be a lot
safer again this is just probabilities
there's no there's not a big body of
evidence for this it's really just what
we know about how different products
interact now a treasure Nolan
um I don't think this is a problem
obviously there will be holes there's
the potential for holes but trashinome
was never meant to form an anti-fill
um the way treasure Norm works is the
molecules get in and they change your
skin from the inside and we can say that
because it's a drug
um it changes your skin from the inside
um
but this happens over a long period of
time like you can't use tretinoleum once
and have like expect to have effects
you're using it
um I don't know over let's say at least
probably like two weeks a month
um so you're using it 14 times when you
do it like let's say 14 times the holes
will be in different places and so it
will even out over time and so I think
it is fine if you mix it in your hand
um there has been a lot of talk about
um layering versus mixing as well with
treasurement and again I think it's like
um I think they are different but not
for the same reasons as sunscreen
um so the reason I think they're
different is
um your skin will absorb stuff
um so you've got your skin model
um
that's a product that I just didn't find
a place to store I'm not endorsing that
product if anyone works out what it was
um yeah so here's your skin skin model
you've got the top stratical name that's
the dead layout and that's actually
um it can absorb some oils and stuff
um this is actually something I'm I was
going to do a video on and I forgot
um but someone on sorry I'm just going
everywhere today
um
but it's an interesting tangent I think
someone tested sunscreens on their skin
and how well different products remove
the sunscreen and they found that with
some sunscreens nothing removed it
um and the reason I think that happens
is because
um well I pretty much know this is why
um the top layer of skin
um skin is not like a piece of glass
skin is has that brick and mortar
structure so you've got the dead skin
cells and then you've got the oil in
between them and so when you apply
something on top that's oily those oils
will start mixing with the oils in the
mortar part that's how things like
Vaseline
um will have like an extended effect on
your skin and chemical sunscreens absorb
a little bit into that top layer and so
if you're trying to remove it with
cleanser some of it might not be removed
so you can still see it with a UV camera
anyway where I was going with that is if
you're putting um a product on your skin
like trash and Allen it will also sink
in a little bit
um because tretinoin is oil based
um now if you put if you mix your two
products together before applying then
you're diluting the tretinoin and so the
stuff that sinks in will be diluted
um and then it'll go through your skin a
bit slower
um the reason that's actually not
um not a problem again is because you're
not putting that much tretinoin on your
skin in the first place so that
pea-sized amount is what gets
distributed all across your face
um so yeah just having moisturize in
there a bit of moisturizer just mixes it
a bit more evenly makes it more easier
to spread hmm
now if you put a layer of let's say
vaseline on your face first and then the
treasurement the Vaseline actually
um will saturate or it should saturate
the top layer
um and so any treasure known you put on
top is going to absorb a bit less easily
um so you're less I think it should slow
down absorption
um which is good if you're trying to
slowly start on treaching on because it
can be so irritating so I think there is
there could be a slight difference there
between mixing and like applying
something underneath in that like sort
of Sandwich method that people have
started describing it as
um yes I think there might be a slight
difference there I don't know if it's
really enough to make that big a
difference
um but yeah anyway bowels are very very
long answer to mixing tretinoin
basically I think it's fine if you mix
it in your hand and then apply it each
time not if you mix the whole bunch
okay
um
studying okay so this question from I'm
really bad at pronouncing names I'm
sorry um Andreas I think I'm studying
food science so I relate a lot to
content there's so much oh sorry this is
not a question but thank you
um
yes there is so much misinformation in
both food and
um cosmetics and if anyone isn't already
aware food science babe
um on Instagram and on Tick Tock she's
great I love her work because she's one
of the few people I think
um explaining the science behind food in
a way that makes sense and really going
in depth into it which is yeah it makes
more sense I think that way how
dangerous is Dan DM High down to it
um not very I think so Dan Jin
taijantuan is a preservative that's um
it's in a lot of hair products like
shampoos rinse off products and it's
been demonized I think again because
um a lot of people tend to
pick the preservatives and products as
things that are causing
harm causing hair loss and yeah so there
was a tick tock Ashley that was one of
the first
videos I posted on Tick Tock
um which was Anthony Dr Anthony Yoon
Tony Yoon he posted a video going
um damn Dome High gentleman is a
formaldehive really so if that sounds
really scary don't use it
um essentially I'm paraphrasing um I'm
sure he said it in a much more
convincing way
um but yeah so it is a formal High
releaser
um but formaldehyde is not as scary as
it sounds it's not great for you
obviously but
um your body actually produces
formaldehyde as part of respiration
um I think it's something like 90 grams
a day 40 grams a day something like that
um and yeah that gets processed so
formaldehyde is not automatically bad
the amounts of formaldehyde released by
Dan Dam High Dental now tiny so it
breaks down really slowly over time and
turns into formaldehyde which then
controls the microbes in your product
um so it yeah again just like any other
ingredient used in cosmetics there are
guidelines for how much cosmetic
formulators should be putting in and
those guidelines are based on
toxicological assessments
um and DM hydrogen is a preservative
which means it gets scrutinized a bit
more
um it's on that EU list of allowed
preservatives with a percentage and yeah
like people follow those percentages so
in general it's very safe if you're
allergic to formaldehyde
um some people are they are sensitive to
lower levels and in that case some
people are actually sensitive to these
releases as well even though they have
such low levels
um so in that case I think there as an
issue
um I guess it can also be irritating if
your skin is a bit more on the sensitive
side
um yeah so in terms of safety it's not
very unsafe I think again just like with
um olaplex which I talked about recently
um there's just been a lot of hair loss
lawsuits so damn gym hydentulum was in
that
um Tresemme lawsuit
um and yeah I think a lot of that is
actually a combination of covert and
stress so hair loss is a common side
effect of covet and a cover side effect
of stress and I think pretty much
everyone in the last few years has
either been really stressed or had
covered or both and yeah so there's all
this hair loss and if you're losing hair
and I don't think everyone knows that
these things cause hair loss if you're
losing hair and you've been using
something recently
then you kind of think it's the hair
product and I think that's where a lot
of these are coming from
um yeah
um what makeup do I use
um I've mentioned it before
um in terms of foundation I use a lot of
different Foundations at the moment I've
been using well at the moment what's on
my face is the L'Oreal true match nude
in
um two to three light
um this has been quite nice I've only
used it a couple of times
um so far but it's been really lovely so
far
um I've also been using Trini London's
um
can't remember the name of it but it's
in like a silver tube that one is really
lovely
um probably my favorite foundation for
put it on your skin and if you go out
into everyday life you look really nice
and it looks like your skin
um in terms of blush
oh
um this is my blush which is a
Indonesian brand which I got given a
while ago so
um it's a powder product so it should be
still okay
um but yeah it's like a this is really
dirty so you can see how much I've used
it
um it's like yeah
um something is the brand
um they're Indonesian and one thing I
mentioned in
um the Asian beauty you've read it
video is that in Indonesia I I went
there for um Jakarta
um
Jakarta X Beauty
um which is like a beauty conference
sort of like
um I don't know if people remember I'm
Matt's
um yeah it's one of those big Beauty
things where everyone turns up and you
go around and you buy stuff
um and you listen to talks and it's
really fun it's like a it was in 2019.
um and there were so many brands that I
was asking
um the people who are taking me there
like I've never heard of any of these
Brands like are you ever planning to
launch in like Australia and they're
like International our local Brands
don't really launch outside of Indonesia
because Indonesia has so many people we
like it's a huge Market already
um like it takes years before we can
even
sell like to everyone in the country
before we can even think about going
overseas and yeah it makes sense so
that's one of the brands that is really
really popular in Indonesia and yeah
I've people have just never heard of it
outside of it I think they also tend to
expand into Malaysia as well
um yeah eyeliner is
I don't know where I put it
actually
um face powder
um is this one from Journey which I've
been using forever it's
um their Rose silk finishing powder
um It's Made of starch and yeah I find
starch really good for my oily skin and
keeping me matte for longer
um my eyeliner I think it's discontinued
um
it's the Revlon cream gel
which I went off to eBay and bought once
I realized I thought it was discontinue
I bought like three
um it's
it's really good because it's a pencil
it Blends easily but once it sets it
stays in place much better than other
products I've tried
um I've got really oily Lids so I need
something that stays and the lipstick is
as always always
um Toast of New York
um this is my favorite lipstick I have
like seven of these as backups again
also possibly discontinued
um but yeah really lovely
um I don't know why they don't have more
of this color in other brands
um next one I believe is have I looked
at the new crave SPF um not yet
um they were meant to send that to me
and I don't think it's arrived yet it
could be lost in the mail apparently a
lot of my mail has been getting lost
between the US and here
um DIY glycerin mixed with rose water
and distilled water is good as a
humectant um I think so but the problem
is if you're mixing it
um people tend to mix it for longer and
then keep it for like a week a month
before they use it
um glycerin is very good at preserving
itself on its own because there's not
much border content and so any micro
psycho in there there's not there's no
water for them to multiply
um they can also be like an osmotic
effect where
um it literally draws all the water out
of the microbe and kills it
um it's like honey it's got that sort of
antibacterial effect there or sugar
syrup or Jam like lots of those like low
water high sugar things but once you mix
it with
um rose water and distilled water again
like honey it just turns into diluted
sugar which is great for microbes
um so yeah be careful with that
um I think there are a lot of people
spraying moldy
um glycerin diluted glycerin on their
faces
um thinking that it'll be okay
if you do want to keep it you might want
to look into buying like a preservative
to add to it I don't know if it's really
worth it
um I think it's probably easier just to
add like a drop of Glycerin in your hand
mix it with tap water and then splash it
on your face
um
why does makeup sit so weirdly on some
people's chins it goes blotchy and
patchy but only on your chin
um I can think of a couple of reasons so
your chin is part of your T-Zone so it
tends to produce more oil
um I believe do not quote me on this
it's partly because there's
um a lot more hormone going on there
um so like
um that's the reason why people can
sometimes grow facial hair in that
region
um but also the same hormonal effects
affect oil
um so yeah more oily um I think it's
also because there's more there's
Sometimes some conditions that can
happen there as well like perioral
dermatitis
um and then also it's also partly
because of the oil thing
um people tend to get a lot of clogged
Paws around there and so if you've been
squeezing it I do squeeze them
um it can lead to scarring and so it
tends to be a bit uneven there
um also it moves a lot you can sort of
see it as I'm talking that area moves
around and as it moves then all the
stuff tends to settle into particular
places and it goes watch you
um if your forehead has skin irritation
can you use an active on the rest of
your face or is it best to stop all
actors on face um honestly I think
so this is not medical advice but this
is what I would personally do
um if my forehead started getting
irritated I would probably stop it
everywhere on my face
um I don't tend to be sensitive to a lot
of things so I would then slowly start
it again on small areas of my face
possibly over half my face so I could
compare it to the other half
um and see how that goes but if I was if
I was sensitive to a lot of things I
would probably just stop using it
um or proceed extremely cautiously
um yeah it depends on what the I guess
it depends on what your own risk is
um yeah Bellow sunscreen I've never
actually heard of that um oh it sounds
like it's a Filipino sunscreen I don't
know if it's just again like one of
those products that
um is popular they have enough customers
in the Philippines that they don't have
to take it out although Australia just
doesn't tend to get stuff so
um
yeah um how do you keep pause clear when
you're prone to Club pause
um I for me what works best has just
been Alpha hydroxy acids
um like lactic acid glycolic acid
um yeah I don't know why that seems to
work better than salicylic acid for the
clogged pores um not the blackheads so
on my nose salicylic acid tends to work
on my jawline where I get a lot of Club
pores from things like sunscreen
um glycolic acid and lactic acid
um it's too much skincare products not
good in an early age I think
I don't think it's necessarily bad but I
think it might be unnecessary
um yeah a lot of the time when you're if
you're young and you're using sunscreen
I think that's probably the best thing
to do you're probably not getting as
much benefit and you probably have a
smaller budget
um because you haven't had as much
lifetime to accumulate money and
experience that will get you more money
so I think yeah the cost benefit ratio
isn't that good but if money is not a
problem and time is not a problem then I
don't think there's anything that will
really damage your skin in the long line
it's just not it might not be worth it
depends on who you are though
um as a lake acid is a stubborn hormonal
skin issues is it okay and also is it
okay for someone with eczema um atholic
acid I always have mixed feelings on it
because
um acetylic acid is kind of weak I think
most people have realized this because
products have to be like 10 15 20
before like that's the sort of products
you get that will have azelaic acid as
the star ingredient
um so I think some it is it is gentle
but also not and I think yeah sometimes
it's just because there's so much of it
it's gritty when it goes on
um it hangs around in a high
concentration at the top of your skin
for a while so I actually find that it
kind of itches a lot
um I haven't really gotten past the
itching stage it will always
feel irritating when I put it on
um so yeah in terms of whether or not
it's okay for someone with eczema um it
it can be
um but maybe proceed with caution like
with everything else with eczema
um stubborn hormonal skin issues
um
it's not going to do anything hormonally
um but it can probably work on the other
aspects I'm guessing by hormonal skin
issues you mean acne
it can act on the other causes of acne
um if there's some evidence that it is
antibacterial I can't remember how else
I have a terrible memory and I feel like
that's pretty clear
um to anyone who's been watching me for
a while
um that's partly why I started my blog
so I could write down stuff and look it
up I have an article on azelaic acid so
yeah I think it can help with hormonal
acne but people tend to have mixed kind
of success with azelic acid but it's um
I think it's a pretty good ingredient
it's worth a try for people who it works
for it's it works really well people
love it
chemical UV filters recommended for
rosacea skin
um
I've tried a few and they make me red I
think in general the newer filters are
probably safer because they're designed
to be bigger they're designed to not get
into skin as easily
um but yeah whether or not you can find
a product that has only in your filters
actually there is one and I can't
remember what it is
um it might be to Kobo I don't know
there are a few
um that avoid the older filters and
those might be a better
um better bet
what's a good sign that you should
downgrade the strength of an active
um
so
um yeah been using a jaffeine point
three percent for nine months and my
skin is still Ultra sensitive due to it
I've been considering downgrading to 0.1
percent
um so in general again not medical
advice I personally
um my warning sign is where my Skin
Barrier is compromised so I talked about
this in my um in the collaboration I did
with Hannah recently about Skin Barrier
my warning sign is when normal products
that don't normally sting start stinging
and that generally means my barriers
compromised which means that stuff is
getting in more easily and that can sort
of have a feedback loop um the
irritation will make the skin barri
degrade more and then it just gets worse
so from previous experience that
is a difficult thing to get out of for
my skin
um so I would probably yeah slow stuff
down but for slowing stuff down it isn't
necessarily just downgrading the
strength there are lots of different
ways of doing that you don't have to buy
a new product so you can dilute it you
can use yeah use less
use less and dilute it so that it still
covers your whole face you can use it
less frequently so you can use it every
second night third night once a week
instead and then slowly build up
you can also do short contact therapy
which is like you put it on like a face
mask wash it off after 10 minutes so
there's lots of ways of slowing down
without getting a new product
um I actually talk about this a bit in
my video on how to start on retinoids
so yeah there's a few more techniques
there
um
how to make
0.025 treasure 9 out of 0.1 tretinoin
um if you dilute
um so
really because with tretinoin you're
using so little
um
if you well I guess with any product
where you're using a really small amount
um if you're using let's say a pea-sized
amount of a product and you want to use
the equivalent of a quarter p
sorry the equivalent of
four times less you might use a quarter
p and then dilute it with moisturizer
because
um
I guess there is this kind of
um thing with concentration and total
dose
and what you're doing is really
this is difficult to explain
um but I will try
concentration and total dose are both
important and a lot of the time total
dose is more important than
concentration
so let's make up a number let's say you
want to get a hundred molecules of a
particular ingredient on your face
um let's say there are 100 molecules in
a peak this is very unrealistic for
anyone who knows chemistry but 100 is a
nice round number so let's say there is
a hundred um
well let's go there's 100 in a lipstick
size one just so I hadn't have a prop
let's say there are 100 molecules there
and you want to
um
I'm sorry I need to I think I need a
better way of explaining it maybe this
will go in a later video but
um yeah if you want to get it to a
quarter of the concentration you can
dilute it four times like use a quarter
of the amount you would normally use and
then dilute it
um but that can also change the
absorption properties so sometimes it's
not that simple but that is probably the
closest you'll get
um
um European Union plans to change the
loud limits of rational
um have I heard about this
um I've seen a bit about it I haven't
read into it that much but um yeah so
there is an sccs opinion on retinol the
EU is actually planning to change a lot
of things
um soon and there's just a lot of stuff
that's happening so don't be surprised
if you hear lots of EU bands going on
um I think most Skin lab has talked
about it
um how chromatogenic is shea butter on
human skin
um I see it a lot in Korean so skin
repair some people break out others
don't yeah so chromatogenicity is super
confusing
um and there's no real blanket rule for
anyone because a lot of it is how that
ingredient interacts with your skin
um including the oils already on your
skin and there's lots of studies showing
that different people have different
amounts of different proportions of um
components in their sebum as well as
different amounts of sebum so I think a
lot of people have heard you know oily
skin tends to get acne more
um there's also people who get acne more
tend to have a different balance of the
stuff in their sebum
there's also people who tend to get acne
more have different bacteria and that
bacteria will will like metabolize some
of these lipids and change the
composition as well it's complex
um is essentially what it comes down to
and that is a big reason for why some
people break out and some people don't
there's lots and lots of reasons though
like
um there's also like the shape of the
oil glands
um so that's actually one of the things
that retinoids can change and that seems
to be part of why it helps people with
acne
um
yeah so and then on top of that on top
of all the individual variation there's
also the product variation
um how much shea butter is in there what
else is the shea butter with and so yeah
that's why it's so hit and miss and
um there is no easy answer
um I would highly recommend
um trying out on your skin or reading
reviews from people for whether or not
it breaks them out
um but yeah you probably won't know
until you actually try it on your skin
does sunscreen actually go bad after the
use by does it just stop being active or
does it go down in efficiency
um my eight month old tube says six
months but it still smells looks and
applies the same okay so
um
shelf life is
an estimate it is oh it is rarely ever
like black and white so the way that
things generally degrade is like a
exponential decay
um
I should have really gotten more props
but
um
I should have organized it so I had like
a thing that I could sketch because I
think that would be easier
so
um
in general
oh that's a terrible graph that should I
should get a whiteboard marker so I can
rub it out okay so that's what it
generally looks like you have more of
the active at the start is that reverse
for everyone oh I'm sorry
um so this is how active something is
and then over time it degrades
um it goes fastest at the start usually
and then slows down over time
um so that's called an exponential decay
and the reason is it starts off faster
is because you've got more at the start
to break down and then like let's say
half breaks down after
what's called one half-life
um and then another half will break down
after the next one it's not always like
that exact relationship but generally
the curve looks like that sort of curve
um so when it stops like the um in
general the
so the use by data is somewhere along
here so it's not like um it's not like
it's like you know
I think a lot of people think it's like
this
um a lot of people think you've got like
you know great tons of active and then
it's suddenly like all goes to nothing
um at the use by date that is not true
um it's a slow Decay and usually ideally
through testing they will work out where
it goes below like a decent level and
then that will be the use by day in
reality it's an estimate in reality they
tend to be safer so they tend to have
the use by date before it drops to a
below an acceptable level
um in Pharmaceuticals I believe the
level there's a number for the level I'm
this is probably wrong don't trust me on
this but it's something like 80
um so when 20 breaks down it that's the
use by date
um but yeah so sunscreen um yeah it's
slowly decaying so at
um if it's passive use by date I
probably wouldn't trust it because it's
possible that they did calculate it
really accurately and then put that as a
use by date in reality that's unlikely
and that's just a safe date and so yeah
you can't guarantee that it's good
there's also things like storage so how
you store your products will affect the
shelf life
um if you store it at high temperatures
that will break down faster almost
always
um if you have it in light that can
break it down faster
um
if you have it yeah there's like lots
and lots of different factors with how
how you store it so if you store it
perfectly
um it is probably
still okay but I would not entirely
trust it I would maybe use it in lower
risk situations so with the sunscreen I
would personally maybe use it when I'm
sitting next to a window in Winter
um and then if I'm going on like a long
walk in summer I would do something well
within the use by date
um yeah again that's like personal if
you you might have a different like Risk
benefit ratio
skin flooding I'm not sure what skin
flooding is
um I've heard it and I was going to look
it up right aftergotten so
yeah
um PIH post breakouts um I think I've
got a video on that there's a bunch of
different products for getting rid of
PIH
um but it really depends on your skin I
personally find vitamin C super
effective for that
um because my pah tends to be quite
shallow from acne depends on your skin
though if your acne is quite deep it
might be different
um I have heard good things about Theta
topicals but yeah
um the best ingredient I think for
pigment in general is
um hydroquinone because it is a drug
um but it's also got a lot of side
effects and you have you're meant to use
it very carefully so yeah lots and lots
of pros and cons
um but yeah I've got a video I think on
PIH with tons of options and if not I
definitely have a blog post on it
treasure now with a ha serum
um
how do I use tretinoin with a ha serum I
like to put the ha serum on wet skin and
seal it in with an occlusive because
that's the only thing that helps my dry
skin but it is too
um oh no oh yeah
um it is doing but it's too irritated
irritating with trash
um yeah so when your skin is hydrated
it's better at absorbing stuff which can
be good or bad depending on whether or
not you wanted to absorb stuff so if you
have tretinoin and your skin is quite
irritated a lot of the time extra
hydration is not a good idea
so
um I would personally
um if that was happening I would try to
put them on at different times so for
example I might
um like you could maybe try using the
hyaluronic acid in the morning instead
of at night and then at night only use
seclusive
um
yeah um so this question is a bit about
vitamin A which I think I've already
answered when applying your topical
vitamin A before moisturizer wouldn't it
dilute the retinoid and therefore lessen
its efficacy so if you're applying the
same amount on your skin
um in total then it shouldn't be an
issue
um so if you're playing a p without
moisturizer versus with moisturizer um
you're still getting the same like
concentration over your whole face once
it's spread out
um yeah so applying before and after um
I'm pretty sure mixing is actually more
likely to
um
to have a larger effect because of that
saturation
um potential if you layer
um roll of nylon six and two and six in
skin care and
um discover its use how they discovered
its usage or its history
um
so there's a lot of polymers in skincare
and in products in general and most of
the time those polymers are there for
texture or keeping them mulching
together
um so they're used as thickeners and
these polymers there's a lot of
confusion about whether or not they're
microplastic and it seems like they are
not most of them are not solid
microplastics by definition are solid
um I've been looking in I've been trying
to I've been working on a microplastics
video for a while
um it's one of those topics that I've
been working on and slowly finding
information because
sometimes getting information about
Cosmetics is um
it's not very straightforward because
there's so much secrecy around
um
I don't know some of it is like
in greeting companies want to protect
their information they don't want their
competitors to find out
um and some of it is just like I think
bureaucracy a lot of people seem to just
not know whether or not it's okay to
tell me things and then
um
or anyone things like I said there was
that thing where they don't tend to give
you much info about an ingredient unless
you're about to buy it and sometimes it
feels like that is pure purely just
company policy and no one knows why
um why that's a thing and they're not
sure whether or not they can give me the
info anyway
um yeah so polymers are complex most of
them don't seem to be solid which means
they won't have the same risks as
microbeads for example
yeah my yeah there's like websites like
ban the microphy where they list every
single polymer and they say all of them
are microplastic and that is definitely
not true
um
but yeah I will probably have a video on
that at some point
not sure when
um
the honest channel did a video oh yes I
still need to watch that so there was a
channel who debated whether or not
tretinoin actually damages skin or boost
collagen
um
this person Wally Cola um didn't find
the arguments entirely convincing yeah I
haven't watched that yet I got told
about it and I just haven't had time to
look into their claims sorry
um
but yeah there are a lot of
um a lot of questions about whether or
not tretinoin actually helps skin and I
don't think any of it is really founded
um so things like whether or not
tretinoin causes fat loss for example
um from all all I could find on that
is a study that wasn't even on rats or
human cells it was literally an in vitro
study on rat cells
um which is very different from human
skin
um so my understanding of the fat loss
issue is that
it's really unlikely to be trashing out
also
um there was actually because of that
rat cell study
um there were suggestions in the
literature that maybe this could be used
for cellulite
um and I feel like if it was good at Fat
Loss someone would have made a retinoid
fat like cellulite cream by now and that
hasn't happened I believe that study has
been around for 10 years so yeah I
really don't think it causes any massive
amount of fat loss I think the reason
why people think it causes fat loss is
um as your skin gets as your face gets
older you do lose fat and I think people
tend to start tretino when they're
starting to get concerned about aging
and so what they're seeing is actually
the Aging changes
um and they're attributing it to the
trash and no one kind of like the hair
loss thing
um and I think the other thing is yeah
when people start on trash and on that's
also the time when they start to stare
at themselves in the mirror a lot
um I think Shireen Idris actually has a
video on this but she a pattern she's
noticed is there are two ages when her
patients start coming in like somewhere
in your 30s and somewhere in your late
30s I think it is
um she said there's this sort of pattern
where people tend to notice their face
change and the face they look at in the
mirror is not the same and that tends to
be when they start going to a cosmetic
dermatologist like her and also starting
on tretinoin so I think yeah what
they're seeing is these age-related
changes and then attributing it to
tretinoin and that's how it started
um and also they saw this rat study rat
cell study
um topical caffeine
um
so
Karen
asked my understanding is that topical
caffeine makes our blood vessels tighter
but when it's in scalp slash hair care I
see it mentioned as wide in the blood
vessels and improving circulation what's
true I'm not entirely sure about this
but I believe both are true
um so I think it's I don't I think it's
like your blood vessels I don't think it
actually makes them tighter I believe
again do not quote me on this I believe
it makes them less porous
um so I think it makes them less leaky
um so your blood vessels are leaky like
the capillaries near your skin they um
yeah so there is lymph which is the
um stuff squeezes out of your blood
vessels and then it's
slowly like goes goes through the rest
of your body back in sorry that is a
terrible explanation
um but yeah so it yeah it does both and
it's not really
um
yeah it's not really that contradictory
so it does both
yes
um new Yin Min blue pigment can be used
as sun protection
um in tinted sunscreen that has blue
pigment anyways how is that idea I've
never heard of that
um I have heard of methylene blue
um being
suggested as a sun protection thing
um yeah I'm not sure but blue pigment
itself is probably not very good for
visible light protection
um
yeah the reason is blue pigment actually
doesn't absorb blue light it bounces it
off
um so it blue pigments absorb
um the opposite color on the color wheel
it will be absorbing orange and
reflecting or scattering blue and in
general things that reflect or scatter
light do not work very well for
protection
um so there's a study from the 90s
actually where they looked at visible
light
um how well a really thick layer of zinc
or
um I can't remember if they tested
titanium dioxide I think they did
um like a really thick white layer how
well that projected and it did not
protect well so it looks like you do
have to absorb the absorb the light to
project against it and the best thing
for that is orange pigments actually
um like iron oxides
um oh yeah sorry this is a continuation
of the honest Channel question but they
bring up they did bring up some
inconsistencies in papers so I haven't
looked at all of the data
um but I'm pretty sure
um yeah I'm not very convinced that
treasure none is overall harmful because
yeah there's just too much there's too
many
um studies there's too much real world
evidence as well with people who've used
tretinoin for decades that it is going
to not make your skin look older
um
well let's get saved I should be saving
this I'm not sure if they'll sit on this
channel or on my
um supplementary info Channel which is
where I put most live things or probably
be in this channel for a while and then
um we'll see how it performs the YouTube
algorithm is mysterious so we'll see how
that goes
um in the country I live in acne skin
care products containing isopropyl
methylphenol and dipotas and glycerate
um with zero State sorry I I can always
I always end up pronouncing that wrong
how do these ingredients work and
compared to benzyl peroxide and
salicylic acid
um so I'm not sure which country you
live in but those two are in
um the Roto mentholation Milano CC as
anti-acne ingredients
um so it is a
cosmeceutical in Japan
um I've talked about them I think in my
first Milano CC review the first time I
reviewed it not not the first time I
tried it though
um yeah so how they work I believe
um isopropyl with phenol methylphenol is
antibacterial
um diet potassium lazarazate that is
from licorice extract it I think it
might be antibacterial
um but it also reduces pigment
um so for post-inflammatory
hyperpigmentation
um yeah so how do they work yeah um how
do they compare to benzyl peroxide and
salicylic acid
um I believe they do not work quite as
effectively I don't know if they've been
tried head to head but my impression is
the literature on those is not as strong
but they also have less side effects
um or benzoyl peroxide in a benzoyl
peroxide tends to be quite a um quite
irritating but it does also work really
well
um it pretty much just
destroys bacteria it just kills bacteria
um salicylic acid is not very
antibacterial I think the main way it
works is mostly by acting as an
exfoliant
um it yeah so it prevents clogged pores
so
um
yeah I would
I don't know I think they all have their
pros and cons
um but I think if you have very severe
acne
um I would probably go with benzoyl
peroxide first
um mostly because it is a drug it's
approved as an over-the-counter drug in
a lot of places
um whereas the other ones are at best
um I think they're just
special cosmetic ingredients
um is it more effective to for vitamin C
rational slash bhh go on Danskin after
using tonal or better to use dry to
reduce irritation
um so for that depends on what you're
after if you're worried about irritation
then dry skin if you want if you're not
as worried about irritation then damp
skin because damp skin will they should
penetrate damp skin better
um if it's dry what's the point of
moisturizing if the Skin's going to dry
um so depends on what's in the
moisturizer the more
um so moisturizers work in a number of
different ways there's occluses
emollients and humectants
um so generally when we say damp skin
versus dry skin what I'm talking about
is water
so if you're using like um
a moisturizer that doesn't contain water
let's say Vaseline or something like
that or not as much water then your skin
won't have that much water
um the
ingredient won't penetrate as quickly so
you're not going to have as much
irritation
um most of the water in a skincare
product is going to evaporate when your
skin is damp it will evaporate over time
like not not over that long even maybe I
don't know half an hour it will be back
to dry so yeah it's about the water not
about the other moisturizing components
that will
um
interact like increase water indirectly
so occlusives if you just put it on an
occlusive it seals in water or reduces
the evaporation of water but the water
that's already in your skin and so you
don't end up with a really wet
um
really wet skin which is what would make
the ingredients penetrate if you have
emollients they change the structure or
yeah in theory they change the structure
of the skin so they change the mortar
and make that a more waterproof
structure and that again is just the
water that's already in your skin so you
slowly build up the water over time
um but if you put on a really watery
moisturizer with humectants which they
tend to be then you are adding tons of
water at the start which will increase
the penetration so
um hopefully that made sense
our tree is altrino tretinoin as
effective as regular track
um I'm not sure about our trainer
specifically sorry
um oh no it just jumped
um
okay
I'm gonna start at the oh no I I've lost
my place
um
and there's a plane outside I don't know
if you can hear that
[Music]
um
okay um I found it chemistry study tips
while maintaining motivation
um that is
um
chemistry study tips depends on which
part of chemistry if it's calculations I
highly recommend practicing
um yeah it's really the more you
practice with the capital Asians I think
the more you develop like an intuitive
sense of how to go about the calculation
um yeah I think that's one of the things
I feel like you kind of miss when you're
just learning chemistry through like
watching YouTube like my videos like
crash course and stuff you're not
getting that
um kind of mathematical practice and I
think that is really handy
um just getting an idea of how the
numbers and concentrations work when you
you change the volume
um yeah what happens when you go from a
quarter P to a proper like a full
pea-sized amount
um and I know the calculations are
really boring and everyone a lot of
people hate them I enjoyed them I don't
know why I found it really satisfying
um but yeah I think that's one of the
things you get from doing chemistry
academically that you don't get from
just kind of learning the um the theory
without that practice
um yeah in terms of learning the theory
I think a lot of it understanding it
really helps
um but unfortunately a lot of syllabuses
emphasize memorizing over understanding
um but chemistry
honestly chemistry once you understand
the
fundamental underlying reasons for
things things like Collision Theory
um
thermodynamics
even in with Organic like nucleophiles
um and electrophiles and how they
interact then you don't have to memorize
as much
um and yeah unfortunately a lot of it is
practice so for organic I think it
really helps if you
um if you practice mechanisms for
example writing out mechanisms writing
out all those curly arrows for
everything
um for calculations it's again practice
and just immersing yourself in it
for other tips I think
um having a visual representation of
some things are really helpful maybe
I'll post some of my favorite ones
um at some point
um maybe maybe to my blog maybe to
YouTube I'm not sure
um but yeah there's some really nice
um diagrams that kind of lay everything
out and Things become a lot clearer when
you see the diagrams
um yeah so maintaining motivation
honestly it's really difficult for with
any subject I think I don't think it's
specific to chemistry
um
yeah I don't have great tips for that
I'm sorry
um I'm well I think I've mentioned a few
times I have ADHD and so motivation for
me usually a deadline helps
um yeah so for this life actually doing
it was just schedule it and force myself
to get up at
um at 8am
which is really difficult for me
um nutritional is too strong for
um eyeless lips and neck but if we DIY
um if we can DIY lower accurate
percentages that are unavailable to make
them work how could we do it
um
I I'm a little bit hesitant to answer
questions specifically treachino but I
can I'll just do like active ingredients
in general yeah just because it's a drug
um and I feel a bit uncom and it's a
prescription drug so I feel a bit
uncomfortable
um telling people to use it in a
different way unless
um like a doctor has told you
um but first off I think
um not all doctors think tretinoin is
too strong for eyeless lips and neck
um usually
or rationalize in general really
sometimes you'll get
um you'll get recommendations to start
slow maybe put some Vaseline around your
eyes for example and then avoid that
area I think that's most common for
um starting on different
um
yeah but I think most dermatologists
will say it's fine for the neck and
eyelids assume your skin doesn't start
getting too irritated
um so I think the fastest way is
probably diluting it in your hand like
literally measure out
um let's say
um a quarter pea-sized amount of your
rational and then
um a three-quarter pee-sized amount of
your moisturizer mix it really well
um in your hand and then apply it like
it was a p of the full thing
um so
the um the general advice for applying a
pea size amount is dotted around your
face and then spread it
um I don't think that's necessarily
better than mixing it in your hand with
a large amount and then dotting bigger
dots so yeah just finding a way of
getting a smaller amount to spread out
as evenly as possible is kind of where
that's going
um
my question has to do with a foundation
Farm by Chic lime it is my understanding
that the product may have lead in it I'm
haven't actually heard about this but
she Glam I believe is
um a cosmetic brand made by Sheehan
which is
um an online fast fashion retailer that
seems to have questionable quality
control so that kind of is a red flag to
me for that Cosmetics I mean it's
possible they did do their Cosmetics
really well but
um yeah based on their reputation with
stringently on other parts of their
business I'm a little bit hesitant yeah
in general I am
not very comfortable with
um buying
products from questionable online places
it
is yeah a bit
Dodge
um
changes with my DIY vitamin C serum um
yes I know when I was using a witch I
haven't used for a while because I've
got so much many vitamin C products I've
been trying
um I actually found that really that
dealt with my hyperpigmentation super
quick
um I was really impressed by how quick
that was
um some people have commented
um with similar effects as well
um obviously it doesn't have a base that
increases penetration like a product
like SkinCeuticals but I think the
freshness kind of makes up for that
compared to a lot of other products so
yeah if you have more time like if
you're time Rich money poor I think that
is an excellent thing to try and also if
your skin isn't super sensitive to
vitamin C because that DIY serum has
nothing but vitamin C there's no
anti-irritant ingredients that might
help like buffer the irritation from it
um yeah so I think it is a good solution
for a lot of people but if you have more
sensitive skin and you're you don't have
the time to make it and you can afford a
uh like more I guess
um more complex more a more complex
product that has more thought put into
it I would probably go with that
um yeah so I mentioned the Milano CC in
my Asian beauty Reddit video and that
one I think is a really good option as
well
yeah I feel like I don't talk about that
one enough but I think it's a brilliant
product
um yeah
um do rational Alternatives actually
work slash compare professionals so far
as efficacy I'm not sure what you mean
by Alternatives
um maybe because
you'll
um I would say no I would say the
Couture even in the one study where they
compare because you're too rational
um they use bakushil twice a day versus
rational once a day so I don't think it
is
that good in terms of efficacy I don't
think I've done a big YouTuber video I
should do a big YouTuber video but I've
got a blog post on it
um
there's too much skin care about the
jeans so I answered that earlier
um basically
it's probably not worth it um can you
use retinaldehyde after benzoyl peroxide
what will it be inactivated that's a I'm
not entirely sure about this one
um I think there's a possibility so I
would probably wait between them
um yeah I would wait between them
I think that's all I can say I'm really
not sure about that one
um
because yeah the benzoyl peroxide will
sink into your skin somewhat and I'm not
entirely sure how long it takes for that
to stop
um being active in your skin
so I would probably try to separate them
as much as possible so maybe benzoyl
peroxide wash like in the morning and
then rationale to hide at night
Nissan youth line
um I haven't looked at the Meson lines
at all actually I've heard good things
about Maison but yeah how do I get rid
of Millie on my face and not trigger
eczema um I think with Millie I think
you'll meant to extract it I would not
recommend extracting it yourself because
it can cause starring
um for Milli prevention a lot of it is
avoiding really heavy products in that
area and using exfoliants
um so whatever exfoliants work for your
particular skin
bonuses Hydro UV sunscreen I actually
have a tube of it there I tried it the
other day it's
um oh I'm not meant to talk about
Australian sunscreens sorry I'm not
allowed to say anything about them so um
yeah so the TGA guidelines say
um
seem to be saying that you can't talk
about
Australian sunscreens in terms of your
own
experience with them I'm not sure if um
yeah I think Hannah also has written a
bit about this on Instagram I haven't
talked that much about it
but that appears to be what the
guidelines are saying so I am kind of
sticking to that now but you are allowed
to say what the product says and I think
you can safely assume that if someone is
talking about a sunscreen and reading
out particular lines about that
sunscreen from the marketing they
probably agree with those lines that
they are saying
and I think if you know that person's
General sunscreen preferences
um and they say they recommend you're
allowed to say you recommend a product I
think if yeah if you know that person's
particular sunscreen preferences and
they say they recommend a product that
sunscreen probably fits in with their
preferences
yes so um I'm very hesitant to talk
about Australian sunscreens
unless I've scripted it in a video
um I do have a video where I'm pretty
sure I have scripted it very safely
um which is my top sunscreen
recommendations of 2022.
yes but yeah if you see an Australian
sunscreen in my recommendations
um
or in anyone's recommendations it is
likely that it fits their sunscreen
preferences let's go with that
um could DIY fermenting um colloidal
oatmeal create smaller and more
beneficial molecules so fermentation
um
I again I have a blog post on this but I
haven't really talked about it on um in
a video yet fermentation there is this
idea that it creates smaller and more
beneficial molecules and that's not
really true so I think the earliest
fermented thing is probably beer or wine
um and that creates
um from sugar it turns sugar into
alcohol like apple alcohol and I think
we can all kind of agree that alcohol on
its own is not that beneficial for skin
the sugar is probably more beneficial
because sugar acts as with good
humectant alcohol on its own
um
apart from being antibacterial which is
nice and helping other ingredients go in
in itself it's not inherently beneficial
so
um that is a myth it does create smaller
molecules though
um and smaller molecules do penetrate
better whether or not they are better
for your skin overall is
a big question mark
um and DIY fermenting is not necessarily
safe if you've ever tried making like
sourdough or um or computer or any of
anything like that
um you'll know that contamination
happens a lot and you have to do a lot
of stuff to avoid the contamination
until there's like a robust
um like a robust Community happening so
I make computer for a while it's really
fun
um but I ended up with way more computer
than I could ever use you have to keep
it at a low PH to try to encourage the
right bacteria to form if you see
particular colors if you see mold then
you have to Chuck up the whole thing
um so I think yeah unless there are very
well established instructions for how to
ferment it I would avoid doing DIY
fermentation
um are you serious on my hands I usually
have to wash my hands a couple of hours
after I apply do I still get the full
benefits if it's washed an hour or two
later
um I think so
um yeah again most of the time
um
the way that products work is they sink
into your skin and then they stay in
that top layer and then once they're in
that top layer they slowly dissipate
into the rest of your skin over time and
so
um yeah I think a few hours later it
should have sunk into that top layer
enough that it will just yeah anything
on top is probably not going to sink in
much further it's probably gonna
especially if it's something like
vitamin C or vitamin A it's probably
going to decompose before it sinks in
um further so it's probably not going to
add that much to your benefits
um yeah that's also why short contact
therapy um like leaving it on for 10
minutes and then
washing it off still gets most of the
benefits of
um leaving it on overnight so that's
with
um the studies they did on retinoids and
short contact
um
yeah can you use humectants without
occlusive yes
um but
so I did a video on
um how you don't so this was a short
actually a yeah YouTube short
um you don't actually need humectants
like you don't need to seal in
humectants
um but I think some people have said
they feel like humectants aren't helping
without the occlusive and I think that's
just because you're not using occlusive
um I think the occlusive itself is
making a big difference and so yeah if
you're using human without an occlusive
you're using less moisturizer so your
Skin's less moisturized
um
yeah what is the actual risk of
cross-contamination with powder and
cream products for makeup artists I'm
not that familiar with it
um
yeah I yeah I'm not that familiar with
things like
makeup artists in there
um their practices I should really maybe
I should look into that
um yeah I'm not sure what you mean by
cross-contamination
is that when you put accidentally like
have a brush and then you've got like
powder and you put it into the cream or
like you've got some cream on the brush
and you put into your powder product I'm
not sure sorry
um I've heard of Evita um I know there's
a bit of a like Community around Aveda
I know some people who are like it's
like that they have lots of very loyal
customers
um but I haven't really looked into them
user and face sunscreens um I've tried
the oil control
um when I was in Europe I bought it and
I really I really enjoyed it it was a
nice product
um it's not it's not legally approved in
Australia though so if you're Australian
be aware of that it's not a proper
Australian sunscreen
which
for my International audience
um I can talk about it
is my understanding
yeah
um best ways to identify ingredient
allergies or intolerance without going
to a doctor
um yeah a lot of the time going to a
doctor might not help if it's an
uncommon ingredient because they will
yeah when they do the patch test there's
like some stuff just isn't in the patch
testing
um
yeah I think it's it is helpful to start
with the doctor but if your ingredient
tolerances aren't on there then a lot of
the time they just go well just do trial
and error I've had that experience with
my doctors
um so I think the best way is to just
keep track of which products are causing
the intolerances and then
um
seeing if there's common ingredients
between the products
um one Pitfall of that method is that
sometimes some ingredients are just
really common and so you'll see them in
every product that you react to or most
products that you react to and you'll
assume it's that ingredient but it
actually isn't it's just you know kind
of like water how water is in every
product that you're probably going to
react to
um so that's one of the things you have
to watch out for but yeah just keeping
an Excel sheet of every product that you
react to I think is a good way also
trying out products on half your face is
a good way so you can all um you can
double check that well you get a better
idea of whether you're reacting or it's
something completely different like you
um you wiped some food on part of your
face accidentally
um
[Music]
powder with tuck is the powder with
chocolate dangerous because of asbestos
morphe Shadow has talc in it now and I'm
scared of it I've done a um a long video
on talc and asbestos
um this was like the not so pretty
episode one
um video that I did I kind of stopped
doing that series because yeah um not so
pretty kind of died down which I was
quite relieved about and I didn't really
want to spend a lot of time debunking
something that no one was really being
convinced by anymore
but yeah episode one was on top and
asbestos
um and
it seems like there's just a lot of
explanations apart from asbestos and
talc causing health problems
um it just seems like not a very likely
explanation and yeah so I've talked
about it in a lot more detail there but
I would personally not avoid products
that
don't have that much talk
um like eyeshadow you're not using a lot
of eyeshadow
um and the amounts of asbestos found in
talc has been really low it's only been
specific
um specific brands that have had it the
FDA did some
um did some surveys like they tested a
whole bunch of
um ingredients on the market I think
they're meant to release a new one soon
but I think the pandemic kind of messed
up the fda's um
the fda's activities so not sure when
that's coming out
but yeah I would personally not avoid
Chalk in eyeshadow but if honestly I
think sometimes if you're not
comfortable after like watching my
content watching other people's other
scientists opinions if you're still not
comfortable I think it's just not worth
it
um I think if it is stressing you out
that you're using it then there's lots
of other products use other products
um yeah sometimes some things just
aren't worth the stress even if
um yeah I mean we're we're human
um we're not perfectly rational people
like we won't it's silly to ex I mean
it's irrational to expect us to always
be rational because we evolved to have
lots of cognitive biases and just like
feelings and gut feelings that are based
on nothing but sometimes they're based
on something
um some subtle cue or something so
um yeah
I guess
um I don't know I don't see this opinion
much from scientists like if something's
stressing you out just even if there's
no good reason like the stress just
isn't worth it um just makes more sense
to pick an alternative yeah
but yeah I personally am not worried
about child
um unless I'm breathing in the tongue in
which case like honestly the child
itself breathing in a ton of tap itself
is not good for you
um breathing in powdered minerals in
general like
um it just tends to stick around in your
lungs and not get moved out of your
lungs very easily so
um
yeah I personally probably wouldn't use
talcum powder because of that and not
because of the Asbestos and that's
actually the reason for the EU having
that warning label for talc um like they
have a warning label saying like
um it's an like I can't remember what it
says but essentially it's something like
don't use it around
children under three and that's just
because of talc powder like yeah the
risk of inhaling tough powder itself not
about asbestos
um I've seen a refillable roll-on
container for sunscreen advertised
recently what do you think of this given
my recommendations yeah I would not ah
I think this might be I don't know if
it's the same product that I'm thinking
of which is
um it's a product for kids I think it
might be a brush like it's a brush for
applying sunscreen onto kids
um and it makes it really quick and lots
of moms love it
um yeah I have mixed feelings about it
because yeah if you have if you keep
your sunscreen in there it will probably
interact with plastic
um one of the big risks of that is that
the sunscreen will leach into the
plastic and so you have less sunscreen
in the sunscreen
um
other risks are like the plastic could
interact with the sunscreen itself um oh
I have a I was meant to do a reel on
this
um a cosmetic chemist
um
her Instagram handle is Ava dot perky
um she was actually this was really cool
she was inspired by
um a real idea about transferring your
sunscreen to a new container and she
actually did an investigation where she
put different sunscreens into different
containers and then looked at what
happened to them over time I think it
was like viscosity maybe pH or something
um I was going to do a real about this
and um it's on the back burner
um but yeah there were changes that
happened to the sunscreen so on the one
hand your sunscreen will change and it's
best if you can avoid that um yeah so if
you put it in each time then I think
that is fine or if you get a makeup
brush and use that to apply the
sunscreen onto your child like squirt
out the sunscreen on your into your hand
makeup brush child
um I think that is reasonably safe
um if you keep it in the container I
don't think it's a safe but if that is
the only way you can get any sunscreen
on then I think yeah some is better than
nothing
um but it's not ideal
um I think if they're advertising it
they should have they should give some
info on it
um ideally if they're making a product
like that they would have they should
test it with a bunch of common
sunscreens on the market
and check that it's fine I think that
should be done more often with still a
warning saying
um if you're like we can't guarantee
that the sunscreen will and that all
sunscreens on the market will stay
stable
um on the Paula's Choice ingredient
dictionary under formaldehyde releasing
preservative it says that those
ingredients can react with amines to
form nitrosamines thoughts
um like it's possible but I don't think
it is a big concern
um yeah so I I love Paula's Choice
they're a great brand but there's some
stuff in the dictionary and
the website that I don't think is
entirely accurate I've talked about
um their alcohol
stuff in a video with kind of Stephen
um who is awesome I his stuff is great
if you don't follow him on Instagram
actually I don't think he posts that
much stuff on Instagram anymore but yeah
his his Instagram post like the history
of his Instagram post his website all of
that stuff is so good
um highly recommend
um yeah so their stuff isn't always
entirely accurate
um I would probably not worry about it
it's more of an so with the format High
releasing preservatives that's more of
an issue in products that where both of
them are there
um and it's sitting around for a long
time so it's a problem for cosmetic
formulators it's not a problem for you
if you're just using two products
together
um how long does it take for skin care
to sink in so I think I mentioned yet um
like it should have sunk sunken in
enough in half an hour
yeah
um I don't think it's a big issue an
hour or two hours later
um how do I go about looking for skin
care that's an interesting question like
what is the process like for me anything
I gravitate towards or anything I try to
avoid
um there is a lot of stuff actually but
it's quite specific to me
um maybe I'll make a video on this
at some point because I think this is a
this could be a really interesting
discussion
um
um yeah I think I kind of mentioned it a
bit in the recent
Asian beauty Reddit video
um but yeah when I look for products I
tend to
actually yeah I was talking to
I was talking to
um ola
um Ola is an Ola is really cool
um he's just so cool
um I don't know if you know who I'm
talking about but his
um his uh he mostly does comedy um and
it's just super relatable
um he's on Tick Tock and Instagram and
he's into skincare
um
in general when I look for products if I
go for user reviews first
um so sometimes I'll look at the
ingredients list sometimes I will buy
things without even looking at the
ingredients list if I trust that
person's opinion enough
um yeah so for example
um bitty snails
um she's a long time Korean beauty
um
blogger change
um I think she mostly just does
Instagram now
she has recommended like there are
products she's used for five years that
she loves and I will I have been trying
a bunch of those products just based off
her recommendation because I trust her
opinion so much
um that to me will always overall
ingredient analysis
um just because like there are
ingredients out there that are
proprietary for example only one brand
will have them and you will just not
find credible scientific information
because yeah there's just not like there
is a lot of science out there about
Cosmetics but some areas are just very
poorly researched by independent
researchers and so
um the best thing you have to go off is
actually peop like first off kind of
like the science behind how something
works like whether or not it can
potentially work and then just people's
experiences Ashley I think I also talked
about this I had like a lab muffin
Matrix yeah maybe that might answer your
question
um in the vitamin C products video which
of which I have only done part one I'm
sorry part two is coming
hopefully later this year but there were
I think I just I think it was a bigger
job than I expected going through all
the vitamin C data because it is so
complex and I just got stuck in lots of
like indecision
um I'm trying to get I'm trying to find
someone to help me with that one
actually and just try to help me like
kick me out of that and give me a second
opinion so I can move on but anyway in
that video I um talk about the lab
muffin Matrix which is just like how I
decide whether or not to a product is
likely to work so that might be
interesting but yeah
um I think
honestly product reviews that you trust
to me will win out over ingredient
analysis unless it's an ingredient that
has a lot of info on it
um
yeah
with hyaluronic acid being a humectant
can using it make your under eye bags
even worse so I yeah no um so I think
this might be from the idea that
humectants can dry out your skin which
I've talked about in a real before so
have a look at that real if you haven't
um it shouldn't dry out your skin more
than not using it
um I think it can potentially make your
under eye bags worse because some forms
of hyaluronic acid the longer chain
links they actually form a film on top
of your skin that catches water as it
tries to leave and that film itself can
make like kind of make your um skin
maybe look a bit wrinklier so maybe
that's what you're seeing
or um yeah you could try using a
different moisturizer like a more
well-rounded moisturizer I feel like
that is
an issue that
a lot of people are seeing like they're
using hyaluronic acid thinking it will
hydrate the crap out of their skin and
that's all they need and that's just not
true
um a lot of people also need occluses
and emollients or their skin will be
happier with them it's makeup toxic for
skin in the long run um I would say no I
don't think there's any evidence that
all makeup will be toxic
um or have any detrimental effects on
skin in the long run
um I should leave this live online yes
um nutritional cream messes with your
sleep is that only no sibo um I don't
know that's interesting I I think it is
um it could be that it's irritating your
face and that's like triggering weird
dreams I don't know
um but that's the first I've ever heard
of it so I don't think that's common
um
is there any proof with the benefit of
using human keratin for Hair Repair
um
I think so keratin is a protein and the
way it works is by coating your hair and
by coating I don't mean like a solid
coat
um a lot of ingredients most hair
ingredients actually work anything
conditioning or straightening works by
attaching to the outside of hair and
depositing like little bits
um and that's what proteins tend to do
but not all proteins will stick to hair
um it's called substantivity and there's
actually a lot of research going into
trying to make things stick to hair
um
like not get washed out when you wash
away the product
um so there's some really interesting
ingredients that are proteins that are
functionalized they've got like
um they take the protein and then they
add chemical they add extra atoms to it
um to help it stick to hair
um it's sort of like I think I might
have talked about amidimethicone
um and how they functionalize that so
that it sticks in a really thin film
which is super cool there's similar
stuff with proteins
so
um yeah there are benefits but most like
it will be either very specific proteins
that will stick to hair and
um
a lot of the better protein ingredients
are actually functionalized protein so
not just straight protein
um there's also a lot of hydrolyzed
protein ingredients like hydrolyzed
wheat protein you might see and that is
super confusing because there's um sort
of like collagen when you hydrolyze a
protein basically what you're doing is
you're chopping it up and there are a
million ways of chopping up a protein
um so proteins are really long chains of
amino acids you can chop them up into
the larger sizes you can chop them up
into smaller sizes
um there are lots of different proteins
like from wheat from
um what else is in hair products silk
soy all sorts of stuff and yeah all of
them depending on like let's say you
have wheat protein if you chop it up
into long pieces or really short pieces
both of those will show up as hydrolyzed
wheat protein on the ingredients list
and you can't tell which one it is and
that's sometimes intentional because if
someone's gone put a lot of work into
making
a hair care product that works really
well they're not going to tell you which
wheat protein they use
um because their competitors might try
to steal that idea so
um yeah there's just a lot of variation
with natural proteins and how well they
work
um with functionalized ones
um there's a bit less variation because
they were purposely functionalized to
work
um
in terms of virtue I haven't looked that
deep into virtue but yeah if their one
works I think it could potentially work
if they try to like bunch of proteins or
they happen to be really lucky and the
first protein they tried worked well
um but yeah I've heard about virtue I'm
not sure about
the explanation behind their products
um if they have data on their products
then I would assume that their one works
yeah
um
yeah so K18 is actually another example
of
um a brand that uses peptides but with
their stuff during their development
process they tried tons of proteins
there's actually some scientific papers
on this
um probably linked on their website I
feel like they would link it but yeah
they go on about like all the tests they
did and they ended up with the protein
through lots of trial and error that
they use and I think that is a more sort
of common path to finding the right
protein for hair repair
unless it's functionalized
um
what is acetylic acid good for
um I've yeah I
it's good for a lot of things but it's
not the best for anything I think
um but some people
find that it works really well for them
um like the benefits
of it because it's so non-irritating
because you can use it with lots of
different ingredients it works out being
the best ingredient
um the main
um reasons for azelic acid acne is the
biggest one
um but it also seems to help with some
forms of rosacea I think it's like in
Australia I believe it's approved for
mild to moderate
popular puscular rosacea
um yeah I think there's also some it
could also work for hyperpigmentation
yeah
um studies for cancer on other studies
for cancer on the eyelids as high as
they claim for the conditions such as
glaucoma the floritis or blocked tear
ducts are playing SPF in those areas can
be extremely problematic
um yes so the eyelids are a common site
for cancer because they are kind of like
pointing towards the Sun and people tend
not to put sunscreen on there
um I would just wear sunglasses
um that is just a much easier solution
plus it also prevents cataracts
um is it okay to ask if how to see what
skin type you are
um it's hard to see when your skin is
quite oily but it might need exfoliation
and see if it's doing these cleansing
and moisturizing so I actually have a
lot on that in my guide to basic
skincare which is my ebook
um I think I've also got some stuff on
there in on my blog
um for free which is in the post is your
skin dry or dehydrated so have a look at
that and if that's not enough there is
more on my blog in my ebook and I am
probably going to put out a video about
moisturizers soon as well
um yeah alrighty so
um
wow it's almost 90 minutes I'm going to
wrap up in about a minute so
um yeah thank you for doing this live
with me this was really fun I hope it
was entertaining
um or at least informative or at least
you you
um either learn something new or thought
about something and might go off and
look into it more
um yeah this is really fun um I'm sorry
I couldn't get to everything there is a
lot I feel like the questions are
gathering faster than I can answer them
unfortunately but I am going to do
um another one oh sorry someone actually
wow thank you for actually putting money
in
um so two pounds and I think YouTube
takes a
30 of that so this is probably I'll
probably donate to charity anyway what's
the best treatment for heat sensitive
skin um I'm not sure I can answer that
I'm so sorry
um heat sensitive skin I'm not sure
exactly what you mean by that
um but there are
um
there are lots of conditions that can
make your skin more sensitive to heat
the most common one
um is probably rosacea in terms of
treatments yeah look at what is causing
the heat sensitivity rosacea is super
tricky um I have several friends with
rosacea and I've talked to
dermatologists who
um specialize in rosacea
um and yeah rosacea is so difficult
um I talked about it a bit in my video
with Hannah
but even from talking with
dermatologists who specialize in rosacea
they've told me not all dermatologists
even know that much about rosacea unless
it's their special interest and there
are a lot of rosacea specialist terms um
who have mentioned that they've had
patients come in from other
dermatologists where it didn't work and
the stuff their former dermatologist
told them was terrible
um and just didn't make sense with how
rosacea happens so
um yeah if you think you have rosacea I
highly recommend going to a
dermatologist who specializes in rosacea
look up their background use Google Maps
Google reviews
um look at
um yeah whether or not they say they
they specialize in rosacea as well
um you know get that checked out I think
rosacea is really under diagnosed
because
in the Skin Care Community we talk a lot
about acne but we barely talk about
rosacea but um yeah it there's a lot of
it
um
yeah sorry I'm not sure that answered
your question
um but hopefully that was
at least helpful for some people
um yeah I am also going to do um an
Instagram live soon as well
um oh lasers for rosacea yeah that one
um that is also another big issue as
well so um depending on the type of
rosacea some types of rosacea can get
like worse with lasers
um if it's not done carefully so yeah
work with a dermatologist who is
specializes in rosacea
um don't just yeah go about doing laser
willy-nilly because there are some types
where lasers can cause like long-term
make it worse like for months
um yeah be super careful it is
um the end but yeah I'm gonna be I'm
going to probably do an Instagram live I
think either next week or the week after
so if yeah you you want to join that and
ask questions as well
um yeah this was really fun
um I'm gonna finish this off
um I'm gonna post this on my channel and
yeah thank you so much for hanging out
with me
uh Javon yeah I need I do need to
collaborate with him um yeah I am I
might end up going to the US later this
year and maybe I can meet him and Esther
um the melanin and it's actually yeah
I'll end with a bunch of shout outs to
people who I think you should follow
um so most Skin lab is actually here
he's great
um follow him he's a toxicologist
oh my God my throat I'm 90 minutes of
talking straight
um Jen of the Eco well is amazing
um definitely follow her as well um
Esther the melanin chemist
um Devon Ford he's a um cosmetic chemist
as well
um Lolita skin Kimmy on Instagram she's
great she's kind of on Hiatus because
um yeah she's she hasn't been posting
that much but she's got so much
um back catalog um it's kind of Stephen
um I'm definitely going to miss people
I'm so sorry if I forgotten you
um Hannah um Hannah English she's on
Instagram I'm trying to get her to go on
YouTube
um
oh I'm sure there's so many people I've
missed I'm so sorry I this was a bad
idea usually I list out everyone I want
a shout out and then so I can't forget
anyone but I'm so sorry if I've
forgotten someone oh food science babe
of course as well for food stuff
um
Rogan Francis Dr Rohan Francis he's a um
he YouTube he does YouTube under
um Med life crisis he's really cool
um the physics girl
um she's currently
um struggling really hard with long
covert
um and she
um I recently went through like the top
150 science YouTubers and there are only
eight women
um a women hosted channels there and she
is one of them so
um yeah she's great and definitely watch
her videos with ads on
um because she's in the US medical bills
are super expensive there
um yeah all right
hopefully see you around on the internet
foreign